so today exciting news for joe biden as
he's getting his first
cancellation of his term and his term
hasn't even started yet
i expect there will be many occasions to
cancel biden in the years ahead during
the course of the
harris administration so um i'll have to
choose my spots a little bit can't
cancel them all unfortunately but here's
a spot
definitely worth choosing joe biden
delivered a speech this weekend
discussing his plans for coronavirus
relief
and he wants to save american small
businesses he said after spending now
he wants to save them after spending
months supporting the policies that are
destroying
them but here he is describing the plan
and how the plan will be implemented
listen focus will be on small businesses
on main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
okay so he says his priority will be
black latino asian native american and
women-owned businesses
not just his personal priority but the
priority of his administration
his government when um when helping
these businesses out
there's a term for this it's one we hear
a lot it's called systemic racism
if that term has any meaning at all then
this must be it let's look at it racism
dictionary definition
prejudice discrimination or antagonism
directed against a person or people on
the basis of their particular
membership in a in a racial group that's
what this is
and it will be systemic in a literal
sense it will be discrimination
by the system now notice something here
he mentions black latino native american
women and asian business owners as the
priority groups
this is a problem because first of all
he said latino instead of latinx
which proves that he's transphobic and
speaking of which
he didn't specifically mention trans
business owners as a priority
or gay business owners or bi-gendered
polysexual drag queen business owners
leaving me to assume that he hates all
those people and is literally hitler
what other explanation could there be
these are the rules now but more to the
point
the inclusion of asians is telling
because asians do better than white
people in this country
economically financially their median
household income is something like
twenty thousand dollars higher
so this already is pretty good evidence
that white privilege is a myth
you know it's white privilege but the
people who do the best here aren't white
so that tears down that whole um house
of cards
it's also evidence that the
prioritization of non-whites in biden's
plan has nothing to do with helping the
disadvantaged
despite how it's being sold because
that's what they'll tell us they'll say
well these are just the groups
it's not about the race it's just that
these are the groups who are most
disadvantaged and so we're
trying to help them out well asians are
quite a bit less disadvantaged they are
more advantaged than whites and yet
they get the priority while white males
are left in the dust
the real point for biden and harris is
simply to punish white males that's the
point
you might as well have saved himself
some time and some words especially as
it's
it obviously strains him to speak words
so he could have saved that trouble
and just said white males will get the
short end of the stick
or could have said we will make sure
that white males don't get any help
because that's the point the point is
who they aren't helping
not who they are helping and this is
what we can expect in the years ahead
the the harris administration with biden
at its figure as its figurehead will be
the most racist in modern american
history the left is
long past hiding its racial bigotries
they blame white males for all the ills
in the world today and through history
and now they intend to punish the
villains and the problem is that most
conservatives as usual
have been too afraid for years to meet
this head-on and call it what it is
they have believed what the left has
told them that either anti-white racism
doesn't exist
or it's not a big deal or that somehow
it's racist in itself
to call it out and oppose it but that
was nonsense
always was he is and was we all know
that that if donald trump had ever given
a speech or he announced a plan to give
relief to business owners with priority
to white males especially can you
imagine that
the entire country would lose its mind
democrats would call for their third
impeachment
and there would be near unanimous
agreement that his plan was racist
nobody would disagree
it's no different here we never should
have allowed the left to pretend
that racism is somehow different when
directed at white males
but that's the lie that has cemented
itself into our culture
the cancer that has metastasized and
we're gonna see how bad it gets because
they literally haven't even gotten
started yet
but for now biden is canceled
so i'm doing my part at least i don't
know what the rest of you can do but i
will at least
cancel him repeatedly hopefully that'll
do something won't do anything
helps me vent anyway helps me
emotionally
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content